>>> FORMER FACEBOOK DATA
SCIENTIST TURNED WHISTLE-BLOWER
FRANCES HAUGENETURNING TO
CAPITOL HILL AND SOUNDING THE
ALARM ON THE DANGERS THE
COMPANY'S PRODUCTS, PARTICULARLY
INSTAGRAM, POSE TO TEENAGERS.
>> FACEBOOK'S INTERNAL RESEARCH
STATES THAT NOT ONLY IS
INSTAGRAM DANGEROUS FOR
TEENAGERS, IT IS SUBSTANTIALLY
MORE DANGEROUS THAN OTHER SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS BECAUSE TIKTOK
IS ABOUT PERFORMANCE AND DOING
THINGS WITH YOUR FRIENDS,
SNAPCHAT IS LARGELY ABOUT
AUGMENTED REALITY AND FACES, BUT
INSTAGRAM IS ABOUT BODIES AND
SOCIAL COMPARISON.
>> JOINING US NOW TO DISCUSS IS
SCOTT GALLOWAY, CNN PLUS HOST
AND PROFESSOR OF MARKETING AT
NYU STERNS SCHOOL OF BUSINESS.
IT IS SO GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON
THIS MORNING TO TALK ABOUT THIS.
YOU KNOW, IN YOUR VIEW, HOW
HARMFUL IS INSTAGRAM TO KIDS?
>> WELL, AS A PARENT, I DON'T
THINK I'M BEING -- I THINK A LOT
OF PARENTS WOULD AGREE WITH ME,
I WOULD RATHER GIVE MY
14-YEAR-OLD SON A BOTTLE OF JACK
DANIELS AND MARIJUANA THAN AN
ACCOUNT.
IMAGINE AT 15, A LOT OF US
MAKING THE DECISIONS DON'T HAVE
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WITH THIS
BECAUSE THESE PLATFORMS WEREN'T
AROUND AS WE WERE IN OUR
FORMATIVE YEARS, BUT IMAGINE
HAVING A FULL SELF OR BEING
PRESENTED WITH YOUR FULL SELF
24/7 AND THEN IMAGINE A PLATFORM
THAT IS VERY VISUAL THAT IS
BASICALLY KIND OF DOMINATED BY
YOUNG WOMEN OR GIRLS REALLY WHO
PUT UP AN IMAGE OF THEMSELVES
AND THEN WAIT FOR COMMENTS FROM
THEIR PEER GROUP, OR TOTAL
STRANGERS.
THE BASIC PREMISE IS A LITTLE
WEIRD AND UNCOMFORTABLE.
I THINK THIS HAS BEEN -- THERE
HAS BEEN A LOT OF EVIDENCE NOW
THAT SHOWS THAT SELF-HARM AND
TEEN SUICIDE HAS EXPLODED,
ESPECIALLY AMONG GIRLS, SINCE
SOCIAL HIT MOBILE AROUND 2012
WHEN FACEBOOK ACQUIRED
INSTAGRAM.
I THINK THIS IS A HUGE PROBLEM.
>> HOW DO YOU WORRY THAT THIS
CHANGES THE PATH OF THIS
GENERATION INCLUDING GIRLS?
>> WELL, LOOK, ANYONE WITH KIDS
KNOWS THAT YOU HAVE YOUR WORLD
OF WORK, YOUR WORLD OF FUN AND
YOUR WORLD OF KIDS AND IF
SOMETHING COMES OFF THE TRACKS
WITH ONE OF YOUR KIDS, YOUR
ENTIRE UNIVERSE SHRINKS TO THAT
KID.
NOW WE HAVE -- I THINK LOOKING
BACK ON HOW WE HAVE REGULATED OR
NOT REGULATED SOCIAL MEDIA,
WE'RE GOING TO REGRET THE AXIS
OF MISINFORMATION THAT IS
DECREASED VACCINATION RATES THAT
WILL LEAD TO UNNECESSARY DEATH
AND DISABILITY.
WE ARE GOING TO REGRET NOT
BREAKING THE COMPANIES UP AND WE
HAVE STUNTED ECONOMIC GROWTH BY
LETTING THEM EXERT THEIR
MONOPOLY POWER.
THE BIGGEST REGRET WE HAVE, I
THINK IN TEN YEARS WE'LL LOOK
BACK, HOW ON EARTH DID WE LET
THIS HAPPEN TO OUR CHILDREN?
ALCOHOL, MILITARY, MARIJUANA,
BUT WE DIDN'T AGE GATE SOCIAL
MEDIA WHICH DEMONSTRATED MORE
HARM TO TEENS, ESPECIALLY YOUNG
GIRLS.
BOYS BULLY PHYSICALLY AND
VERBALLY.
GIRLS BULLY RELATIONALLY AND WE
HAVE PUT THESE NUCLEAR WEAPONS
IN THEIR HANDS.
I THINK IT IS -- I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO LOOK BACK ON THIS AND
THINK HOW ON EARTH DID WE LET
THIS HAPPEN?
>> I HAVE APPRECIATED HOW MUCH
YOU SPEAK ONLINE, JUST SHOUTING
FROM THE ROOFTOPS TO PEOPLE
THAT, LOOK, IF IT COMES DOWN TO
OUR KIDS, THAT'S REALLY ALL THAT
MATTERS.
YOU SEE CONGRESS BECAUSE OF
THESE PLATFORMS INVOLVING
SPEECH, THEY SEEM UNSURE OF WHO
TO LEGISLATE THIS.
WHAT ACTUALLY WOULD PROMPT
CONGRESS AND BIG TECH TO ADDRESS
THIS?
>> IN A WORD, MOTHERS.
IN THE '80s, THE ALCOHOL LOBBY
WAS VERY POWERFUL AND RESISTED
ANY ATTEMPT TO RAISE THE LEGAL
DRINKING AGE.
AND THEY PUT SO MUCH PRESSURE ON
CONGRESS BECAUSE SO MANY OTHER
KIDS WERE DYING IN DRUNK DRIVING
ACCIDENTS THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOUND A CREATIVE WAY
TO INSPIRE THE ALCOHOL LOBBY TO
CHECK BACK AND THAT IS THEY
WITHHELD FEDERAL FUNDS FOR
HIGHWAYS.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEEING SOME THE
EQUIVALENCE OF MAMS.
I THINK THEY HAVE CROSSED THE
WRONG COWBOY HERE, SPECIFICALLY
MOTHERS.
IF YOU'RE IN A HOUSEHOLD WHERE A
CHILD IS SUFFERING FROM A EATING
DISORDER AND YOU FIND YOUR
15-YEAR-OLD WHO IS 5'10", 100
POUNDS IS BEING SUGGESTED
EXTREME DIETING SITES, THE
ALGORITHMS HAVE DECIDED TO
SUGGEST THESE SITES TO YOUR
DAUGHTER, YOU CROSSED THE WRONG
PERSON.
THIS TAKES IT INTO AN ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT LEVEL AND I THINK
PARENTS, I'D LIKE TO THINK ARE
GOING TO PUT PRESSURE ON OUR
ELECTED OFFICIALS TO FIGURE THIS
OUT, LISTEN TO MISS HAUGEN WHO
PUT ON A MASTER CLASS IN HOW TO
BE EFFECTIVE VERSUS RIGHT.
I APPRECIATE YOUR WORDS, YOUR
KIND WORDS ABOUT ME, A LOT OF ME
AND MY COLLEAGUES HAVE NOT BEEN
THAT EFFECTIVE.
WE HAVE HAD A TON OF THESE
HEARINGS AND NOTHING HAPPENED.
THIS SHOULD BE THE PART OF THE
PROGRAM WHERE WE MOVE TO ACTUAL
LEGISLATION AND IMPACT WHERE WE
BEGIN TO PROTECT OUR YOUNG GIRLS
AND OUR YOUNG BOYS.
>> YEAH, WE CAN'T JUST SIT BY.
WE CAN'T JUST SIT AND WATCH
THIS -- IT IS A HORROR SHOW
REALLY UNRAVELING IN REAL TIME
BEFORE US.
AND SCOTT GALLOWAY, I APPRECIATE
YOU JOINING US TO TALK ABOUT IT.
>> THANKS, BRIANNA.
>> AND I'LL SAY WELCOME TO CNN.
I GOT STUCK IN AN ALGORITHM OF